hello everyone and welcome to the game
you've all been waiting for we are at
the same simultaneous exhibition we've
shown yesterday only I think though for
mentioning in the comments I don't see
how I missed that Aqualung his opponent
in the previous game was not Vashti no
it was actually the the famous Boris
Nikolayevich by shakira of the poet and
well if I knew that he would not be the
hoody guy but as I didn't know that for
some reason in the Eduard the winter
book I have about capablanca it says
bosch tariff and when I googled birch
tier of verses capablanca a Google did
not realize I was actually actually
looking for Barsky reverse capablanca so
that's well it's a shame but you know
the game still stands and it was against
that person but here we have a game
against Sergei Prokofiev famous composer
and aside from being a really into music
here he just finished his graduation at
the Sankt Petersburg Conservatory and he
won major awards for the piano
everyone was congratulating him
Prokofiev was where he had a really busy
day he was just getting back home I was
almost 8 p.m. the simultaneous
exhibition was just about to start he
had like 15 minutes and he realized that
he didn't have time to go home he didn't
have time to even eat he just hurried
and he found a car that was already
going there so he arrived at the
simultaneous exhibition he faced
capablanca and that was the first game
that they played that was played on May
11th the same day he had his graduation
and he lost that game he said that he
was really afraid that Capablanca was
gonna play the Kings gambit against him
but he didn't but it moves to those game
a Musa for that game have been lost I
wasn't able to find them and moves to
the second game they played the second
game was also a simultaneous exhibition
it was four days later on May the 15th
and there there are a few moves
available not by Capablanca Blanca does
not mention this game in his book but
Prokofiev kept a journal I will put a
link to the journal in the description
below
it will be the second thing in the
description you will see the first thing
as it stands the best of Prokofiev you
know if you want to just listen to some
music before we get into this game but
for the second game he mentioned that he
played d4 d5 Knight to f3 and
he prepared in the third game he played
Knight to f3 but in the second game
Bishop to fi was played he says that
it's a trap he prepared for kappa blanka
for the simultaneous exhibition after
c-4 which Papa Blanca played sorry about
that the Prokofiev went for Knight to c6
and he says that he prepared this night
before to see to that he would very much
like to win the exchange and he says the
capo Blanca when he came to his board as
it was a simultaneous exhibition you
know couple Wonka was just strolling
around Kabul Anka came to the board he
saw this position he's so nice to see
six and he was like really trying to
figure out what happened for the for two
or three minutes as Prokofiev mentions
in his journal do check it out it's it's
a wonderful journal but we don't have
any other moves from from game to
Prokofiev did win the exchange but
Capablanca won the game as Prokofiev
says what we do have our moves to the
third game they played that game was
played on May 16 so the day after this
game you can say that Prokofiev was
really a big chess fan and he did not
want to miss an opportunity to play
Capablanca as much as possible so this
game continued in a similar fashion but
instead of Bishop to f5 here we had
Knight to f6 by Prokofiev I just going
for a nice symmetrical setup we have c4
by kappa blanka and now comes the Bishop
to f5 by Prokofiev just developing the
biggest problem in the in the Queens
gambit and in similar Alliance is what
are you gonna do with the dark square
Bishop so here Prokofiev just develops
if she wants to play east six and he
wants to have the light square bishop
already developed but Capablanca
immediately goes for some pressure
attacking well pressuring the d5 point
here but also going after b7 and this
was Prokofiev's idea for the third game
he played Knight to c6 and okay a couple
Blanca grabs the pawn we have Queen
captures on b7 now comes Knight to a5
attacking the Queen we have Queen to a6
now attacking the knight and here we
have Knight captures on c4 and okay I'll
grab revving back the pawn we have
Knight to c3 and now comes east six and
now c4 is an excellent square an
excellent outpost for Prokofiev Knight
but it is Capablanca the opportunities
for some rapid development and here he
wastes no time he goes he for of course
you can do this because you
capture you will remove the defender of
the night and c4 and the problem with
something like Bishop to g6 you just
capture here and after pawn captures
Queen c6 Czech wins the game you attack
the king and the rook so the Queen
cannot block you have to block with the
knight and then just Knight captures you
remove the defender of the night you're
threatening Knight captures here and
also Bishop captures here so you cannot
parry both threats so after a four by
capablanca we have D captures on e4 by
Prokofiev and now capablanca misses the
opportunity as this is a simultaneous
exhibition to go 495 it's a very nice
idea because after captures and captures
Knight d7 you get this Bishop to b5 move
and after Bishop to c5 you get Queen to
c6 and white already has a winning setup
here because black can never castle as
well you would lose a piece here you
can't move the knight you can't move the
Queen you have to keep an eye on the
night so you could harass the bishop for
a bit but the bishop always finds a safe
square on a4 so here amazing position
for white kappa blanka it keeps it
simple after D captures on e4 he doesn't
go 495 he goes for Bishop captures and
c4 grabbing the night we have a captures
on f3 and now Queen to c6 kappa blanka
is preparing a similar idea but first he
has to keep an eye on the g2 pawn with
check
we have Knight to d7 and now g4 removing
this threat and also hoping that if
Bishop captures Capablanca introduces
the rook into the attack but Prokofiev
is not interested with Bishop to g6 and
now just Bishop to g5 with the idea of
course that if Queen captures Queen
captures rook here and of course if f6
then white will just ignore you simply
castles and if the bishop is captured
and Bishop captures on e6 opens up the
e-file the rook can now come into the
game black will be it will be extremely
hard to defend
so after Bishop g5 Prokofiev takes this
opportunity to develop and hastened his
castling with Bishop to e7
with Bishop captures and out the Queen
still can't capture because Queen
captures rook we have King captors on e7
now comes queenside castle by kappa
blanka and now rook to e8 Prokofiev
takes this opportunity to artificial
castle he wants to play King to f8 and
here Capablanca had the opportunity of
going Bishop to b5 it would create a
similar setup that we already mentioned
the King would not be able to escape
because of this threat of Queen captures
on d7 about capablanca first improves
the position even better h4 now
threatening to win the peace with h5 we
have h5 by black G captures the Bishop
captures and now again kappa blanka can
go for Bishop to b5 or he can go for the
immediate d5 but here capablanca chooses
a different life he goes Knight the b5
which is seems to be a lesser move
because there is never really a threat
of capablanca capturing here but you
know if you're if you're holding a
simultaneous exhibition you will you
will not always go for the absolute best
move here Prokofiev took this
opportunity to go King to f8 as well you
can't capture here if Knight captures
then rook c8 just wins the piece even if
you save the night by Queen d6 check
rookie 7 you still can't move it if you
move it then you lose the bishop the
bishop is also unguarded on c4
so after this King to f8 cup of vodka
played d5 and okay of course he wants to
open line so the King on FF the King on
f8 is a bit suspicious there we have
Queen to f6 by Prokofiev and now D
captures on e6 opening up an attack
against Prokofiev his knight here we
have Knights to e5 with an attack on the
Queen and also the bishop Queen to c5
first with check King to g8 and now even
he captures on f7 now you can't capture
with the night if you capture with the
knight you lose the bishop on h5 so you
have to capture with the bishop we have
Bishop captures on f7 and now comes
Bishop captures Queen captures and now
King to be one of course you want to
move your queen or a king away from the
C file as this is a weak pawn you do
want to win at some point so you don't
want to allow this room to see it to
count well your king is still on c1 rook
8 to beat by Prokofiev so here if you
count everything up it's four points
Prokofiev four points capablanca I
wouldn't really sharp position castles
of opposite sides you know it's really
just a crazy position and here a couple
bankers should you just go rook H e1
a centralized and
you know claim that he's a better player
and that he will slowly but surely win
this but here kappa blanka like Arnold
Schwarzenegger Oh yesterday plays Knight
captures on c7 and it's a it's a really
interesting idea but it doesn't seem to
work here his opponent of course you
cannot go here because you lose this
Knight but of course Prokofiev just
played rook beat the c8 and now what do
you do with the knight how do you defend
it here kappa blanka played rook the c1
just you know adding another defender to
the night and although knights the d3
can be played here with an attack on the
bishop and the queen / coffee place an
even better move he plays rook to e7
just adding a third attacker to the
night and now there's no more saving
saving the night here Queen captures and
d6 is played and it could be that this
is the position that couple Blanca saw
but he just blundered because most
likely he saw that after rook captures
rook captures maybe he saw Brooke
captures and Queen captures night but
here Prokofiev just played the Queen
captures on c7 and a couple blanca is
just down a knight
I mean down a piece and you have to be
very careful if you play something like
Queen before you can even run into
checkmate of course you all see it Queen
c2 check King has to move and now a nice
Queen sacrifice for for a very nice rook
c1 checkmate
so after Queen c7 Capablanca has to try
something he plays Queen e6 check King
moves to h8 and not just a three
preventing any Queen c2 checkmating
ideas we have King sorry we have Queen
to c2 check King to a1 and now comes
Knight to d3 threatening checkmate
Capablanca has to go further into
passivity now we have rook to be won and
now comes Knight to f2 just grabbing a
pawn so it's really really just a
terrible position for a problem got to
be in he has no activity okay the Queen
is active but the Queen alone can't do
all that much and it's really hard to
imagine creating some sort of a
perpetual check mating sequence now but
first couple Monica goes for h5 he wants
to push h6 and well if he must opened
the the last point that's defending the
king perhaps he can hope for some sort
of a perpetual check but okay Queen to
see sex Prokofiev wants to trade Queen's
cover blanc of course declines Queen to
five still keeping an eye on the rook
maybe keeping around on the pond here
but Prokofiev the great composer that he
was still continues composing even in
this game Knight to e4 he offers the f3
pawn for this night the d2 idea and
there's not all that much Papa Blanca
has to choose from if you if you just
push h6 then f2 will be very dangerous
just creating a super powerful pass pawn
so Capablanca captured the pawn and we
have night to d2 with an attack against
the Queen and the rook so capablanca has
the trade Queens now we have Queen
captures rook captures and now rook to
d1 we have looked the c2 now defending
the knight but also not allowing couple
on cut any counter play we have looked
the g1 now comes rook the c5 attacking
the pawn and now rook to g6 Capablanca
wants to give up the h5 point for the a7
point we have rook captures on h5 and
now kappa blanka plays rook to a a 6
going after the a7 pawn and here if he
can eliminate the a7 pawn then okay he
does have two connected passed pawns on
the Kings side maybe that could be in a
way compensation for the piece and with
some luck maybe you know maybe anything
can happen but here Prokofiev again just
you know just shows Capablanca how it's
done I feel free to pause the video here
and try to find a way to defend the pawn
in a 7 I'll give you a couple of seconds
if you want to do it as usual for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
composer not like Prokofiev but
excellent and for those you who just
won't enjoy it show Knights the b3 check
King - a - and now the move you have to
find because your knight is under attack
rook to a5 and now of course if King
captures night then rook captures rook
so here if you move the rook let's say
rook c6 just would be 5 defends the
night and then the pawn can be pushed
forward so here Coco Blanca saw no other
way but the trade rooks he played rook
captures rook we have Knight captures on
a5 and here we have B 4 and here
Prokofiev instead of just moving the
night he says I'm a great composer I
mean III compose whatever I do even when
I play
chess and he just played g5 he shot a
couple Blanca how it's done he said I
don't mean my knight you can you know
you're free to capture it if you capture
it then g4 and the King is nowhere
nowhere near to stopping the pawn for
those of you who like to draw things out
you can see that the king is too far
away from from the square of the pawn he
would need at least at least three moves
to get it to get in there
so of course black would be winning here
so after g5 couple Blanca played came to
be two but then for coffee we'll just
play g-force still not interested in his
night and it was in this position I move
43 that was a roll kappa blanka resigned
the game so after two losses the third
time Prokofiev faced capablanca at the
game ended in a in hin final you know
win for Prokofiev and he was he was very
happy extremely happy about it you know
people are congratulating him it was
really awesome but do check it out I
only mentioned a few details from his
journal he has details from all the
three days he went to a simultaneous
exhibition against kappa blanka and
mentions a bit about every game but we
only have a few moves again from Game
two yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoy that kappa blanka most likely
didn't but after the game both
Capablanca by shakira and the Prokofiev
went with bashir up to his to his place
were bashed get off with the brag about
his two other new cars that he bought
and then bas Pierrot asked Prokofiev to
play Tann Heuser for Capablanca and him
and he agreed because he wanted to hear
a couple bonkers opinion on it it was a
his pre lute for the harp and the couple
says he said it was alright he approved
of it and he heard that he said that he
heard that somewhere already which
Prokofiev knew it was impossible because
you know he he composed it so there's
that you know Capablanca was integers
but wasn't really aware of what's what's
modern in in music and also
emmanuel a square also met Prokofiev
during one of these simultaneous
exhibitions and he said that even though
he wasn't much of a music man he still
congratulating Prokofiev for his great
achievements because well everyone else
was congratulating him as well but yeah
a lot of really interesting ideas
had teacup Ibaka was very tired you know
he was just staring at his teacup and
they didn't talk much but later they
sure to walk home so really interesting
journal do check it out it will be the
second thing you will see in the
description below first as usual for for
when we talk about Sergei Prokofiev will
be best of Prokofiev check it after you
if you want to still listen to some of
his music and yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it
Sergei Prokofiev met capablanca over the
board one more time also in a
simultaneous exhibition in Manhattan
chess club I don't know the results to
that game but I don't know I think I
want it if Prokofiev wanted he would you
know definitely share the moves with
everyone like like he did with this game
but yeah that's the game a lot of you
have suggested it so I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank and
Rima cuca the Lu guard recipe pricing
Bobby treat and Paul staples for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos here
and thank all for watching and I will
see you soon hopefully with some more
interesting content and we are
continuing the capablanca saga were
preparing for the for the regime of
Memorial and also for the for the green
tea chest classic and so on and so on
Maria thank you all and I will see you
soon have an excellent rest of your day